[Music]
well hello there watching the press
preview
a first look at what is on the front
pages coming up then we'll see what's
making the headlines with christopher
hope
chief political correspondent at the
daily telegraph
and alison morris columnist at the irish
news
great to see both of you uh so let's see
what's on the front pages then as ever
sixty thousand coming home is the
metro's headline as fans prepare to
attend the euros final at wembley
stadium in the biggest
official mass gathering in 16 months
the daily mail front page features news
that fully vaccinated britons
may be able to enjoy quarantine free
holidays
from as early as july the 19th
the delhi mirror also leads with that
story adding that unvaccinated
children may be allowed to travel
the eye reports that scientists are more
optimistic
that the link between coveted infections
and serious disease
is weakening the telegraph leading with
michael gove's comments that boss
johnson will not grant a new scottish
independence referendum
before next the next election ministers
are pushing ahead with plans to sell
publicly owned broadcaster channel 4 as
part of a
controversial shake-up that's in the
guardian financial times reporting that
more than 5 million people have become
millionaires despite the pandemic while
the number of those worth at least 50
million
dollars increased by almost a quarter
the yorkshire post's headline
north plunged into debt by virus as the
region faces what it calls
an avalanche of dead accrued during the
pandemic
well no doubt we're waiting for a couple
of papers most of them seem to be in
didn't they normally a bit later when
there's football
uh so tonight then joined by christopher
hope chief political correspondent at
the
daily telegraph and allison morris
columnist at the irish news
great to see both of you um well uh you
know
commiseration to scotland but uh but
england did it i guess christopher
yeah yes and just by the skin of their
teeth i mean two
goals in three games we've still got you
know got
the seven points we need need to go
through the question is what's around
the corner it's like we're just
charging off with this uh with the uh
you know we've escaped the group stage
and we're charging into the lion's den
facing maybe germany um or france or
portugal i think i mean it's going to be
quite a difficult time next time
yeah absolutely any of those sound quite
daunting don't they
but i mean obviously a lovely picture on
the front of the daily telegraph
with two of the players including raheem
sterling who thank goodness is scoring
some goals
uh on the front page but down the bottom
which takes us to our next story
um is hypocrisy claims over free pass
for
for euro vips um the telegraph saying
that boris johnson
accused of hypocrisy for allowing
thousands of football vips
to attend the final matches of euro 2020
without quarantine ministers facing they
say a backlash
over the decision yet to be signed off
by public health officials
at the metro in rather more celebratory
mood about it alison
um 60 000 fans at wembley for the
for the euro 2020 semis and final i mean
many people saying this is
exceptionalism for
for football what about every everybody
else who wants to be in a crowd
and you know i i don't know why but like
even thinking about 60
000 people being in a crowd seemed so
strange after the year and a half that
we have had where we've all been
socially distanced i think this will
make wembley three-quarters full 75
capacity um and i suppose that the
questions will be you know how is this
going to be managed they've been having
those
sort of test outdoor events you know
huge concerts and things that have
happened to liverpool but they've been
done with very careful testing
um and checks up checkups afterwards and
people are tested going in and tested a
few days later
obviously that's not going to be
possible with a crowd of that size and
also what are the travel arrangements
going to be we already know
that there's a controversy over boris
johnson and some of the vips to skip
quarantine i think that's probably why
the government's looking
at new plans to sort of open up travel
to try and sort of curve off that
you know accusations of hypocrisy or
early dism
um but i mean it would be great to see
large events happening again i for one
you know will
will welcome them i can't wait to be in
a concert in our large a large crowd
again
you just hope that you know it is safe
and hopefully the vaccine is the game
changer
um and it's not going to see a spike in
in cases yeah i mean there was a threat
wasn't there that the game could be
played in hungary or the italian prime
minister wanted the
the final there and the problem is for
some people watching this
is the government can declare anything a
pilot in order to get the people through
the door effectively
and yet many parents can't go and see
their kid in a sports day
entirely on a school playing field all
theater fans can't go to the theater
so once you start allowing some groups
of people to have rights and others not
people feel aggrieved which will
come on to our next story in a moment
but what's your feeling on this
christopher
well it's politics isn't it i mean
essentially boris johnson knows that
you win football games as that will rub
off on the politicians at the top of the
country
it's happened before to to wilson in the
60s when in the 66 world cup final
there's no question that boris johnson
knows if you can get wembley nearly full
that will trigger this uh this feeling
of of of relief on outpouring of support
and of
for the english players he knows that
football is always going to work for
politicians
um i totally get how frustrated parents
will be
facing what should be a normal run into
the end of term with
sports days and other events but the
problem is that uh when you when you're
looking at football
it is a national sport it's a shared
thing i'm not sure how many watch the
games tonight on itv but 20 million
watch the uh the england scotland game
on itv
on saturday so you know it does reach
so many people and we need a lift at any
point but it'll be brilliant to see
wembley
three-quarters full fantastic yeah it
was on friday wasn't it was it that
memorable
for you come on what do you mean
um but that takes us doesn't it um alice
into an extra which is in the daily mail
which is at what point do you say
if you're double jabbed you can do
something when not everybody is double
jabbed uh
travel has been one of the main areas
for this what is the daily mail telling
us about when travel might be allowed
well they're saying that the the masters
are looking at lifting the quarantine
for anyone who does have a double job by
mid-july
and you know it's one of the things i
suppose that we talk about most now is
when we'll be allowed
to travel again once i read this story i
actually
put a couple of lines from it into my
group chat with the rest of my friends
and they're like get on and get your
flights books they were gonna be allowed
to travel
people are dying to get away on holiday
i have friends who live abroad and i
haven't seen them and
one of them had a baby and i bless her
very much and i can't wait to be able to
to go and see her without quarantine and
i think that when we were told if you
know if we all got facts in it and did
the right thing
well then things would open up quicker
and we would be allowed to get back to
normal as quickly as possible
um i'm not sure what things are like
currently at the minute in england but
in northern ireland we have no patients
in icu whatsoever
the the only patients covered patients
in hospitals are in single figures and
despite the fact that we have this new
variant the cases have stayed
reasonably quite low and continue to
drop and that shows maybe that the
vaccine is effective against this
and if it is well then i'm sure that
there could be an arrangement made with
people
if you have both your your um jobs and
you're
then not you know labeled to be
susceptible to any
other variants that you should be
allowed to travel because you know
remember travel is about more than just
those big you know multinational travel
companies
it's about all the people who work in
airports and the baggage handlers and
people who work in restaurants and
airports and all sorts of other things
there's so many jobs
and livelihoods that depend so much on
travel resume and again
go on christopher well i'm not so sure i
i really want to feel
the the upbeat feeling about this
headline blueprint for
holiday lift off i just wonder what the
impact might be i mean if it does result
in a ticking up of
of cases in other parts of the country
as people come back from being overseas
will that shut down pubs locally will
that end livelihoods
in in pubs restaurants bars hotels well
i'm just trying to claw their way back
into having some form of livelihood and
so my my worry is
that can't people just take a bit of a
breather maybe not go on holiday this
year unless you really have to obviously
you me maybe people are ill getting
married marriage funerals overseas they
are the vital things but maybe hold off
on having a holiday until we get past um
the concern about this virus because you
never know how
the politicians are going to react to
more concern from the scientists
and and medical experts so my concern is
great but if the cases do tick up
please government don't just shut down
the country
in this country i don't think it should
be
for all i mean i'm not saying there
should be a travel free for all clearly
there should be restrictions
at our reports and courts and that
should include testing and i think it
should still include
quarantine from very high risk areas but
the rest of europe
are playing along with their vaccination
program there are cases down as well you
know as i said my friends in valencia
region they have almost no cases at all
um and if we can come to a mutual
arrangement with those countries
then i can't see why we can't get travel
and ask people to have a test when when
they come home at the airport
you know we have advanced technology
that these tests are almost instant now
there's no reason
that context can't take place i mean the
problem is we're the one with the delta
variant aren't we
um you know the place you're more likely
to get coronavirus is queuing at an
airport
while struggling borderful staff try to
check all your paperwork
you know i mean belgium has uh has now
put the uk on
what they call the very worrying list so
if you travel back to belgium
you've got to quarantine having been in
the uk we're the danger people now
yeah well i would say i i i i would hope
that government doesn't overreact to a
slight uptick in cases i
it's great if you're double vaccinated
why can't you go overseas
of course this does bring into the into
the into focus the generational
difference because most over 50s over
40s
um i've had their second jab but those
young people can't get even their first
job in some cases so
it will mean that older people can go
away and younger ones can't
yet again it feels like the young people
are having a hard time in this coat in
this cubic crisis
yes and and nicola sturgeon giving her
best estimate on when all adults in
scotland
might expect to receive both
vaccinations which was sunday september
the 12th
so that is a date to hang on to at least
for scotland uh presumably roughly the
same here too
um very quickly if you don't mind at the
ft and the contrast with the yorkshire
post
uh ft more than five million people
become millionaires despite the pandemic
yorkshire post north plunged into debt
by the virus allison just quickly on
that if you don't mind
yeah so i mean these stories i think
it's it shows that the difference that
we have
in the fact that we weren't all in the
same boat during this pandemic that
there are people who have got very
wealthy
from this and there are people who have
been reduced to almost ruin
by this this ferris you know anyone who
was involved
in those huge you know delivery
companies and providing ppa and medical
supplies and all those businesses that
served
during the pandemic those
multi-millionaires have got richer
the gap between which incurs even
greater and then we look at other areas
where people had no savings they were
furloughed
and already on a low wage and reduced to
living on 80 percent of that
and those people have suffered very
badly and it was created a very unequal
society
yeah okay apology we couldn't talk about
that more maybe we will in the next part
of our program plenty more still to come
including has the government
ruled out a new scottish referendum
before the next election
[Music]
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me our christopher
hope
chief political correspondent at the
daily telegraph
and alison morris columnist at the irish
news welcome back to both of you
um now this isn't a no but and not yet
is that the right reading of this uh
story i'm just checking if it's from you
no you didn't write it
um just checking in in your paper
it's my colleague ben ryan smith our
particular editor it's a really good
story this don't forget scotland the end
is the
the issue of the union and how to hold
that together is one of the
one of the sleeping time bombs under
this administration at this tory
administration because boris johnson
is not popular north of the border now
uh nicola sturgeon has
said she wants to have a referendum by
october
2023 and interview with the telegraph um
overnight michael gove who's the um he's
the main guy tried to hold the union
together
in the capital office the chancellor of
the duchy of lancaster he is saying
no uh indie ref 2 until after the next
election which is
expected to be may 2024 at the moment
although it could be any it could be any
date
really um because they're about to amend
when you can have an election
but we expect it in may 2024 so it just
will put more pressure
on this difficult relationship between
london and edinburgh
yes absolutely and just very quickly
just reflecting on uh what's happening
in northern ireland
clearly another dup leader a bit of an
implosion for the dup the threat that
they may not be the largest party
what does that mean for the union there
as well i mean it's all starting to get
like mr gove's got a lot on his plate if
he's trying to
keep the union together and this is this
is this is the centenary year of the
union today
was the the centenary the 100 year
anniversary of the opening of the the
first northern ireland parliament
and yet you know unionism is in complete
matter flux at the moment you know the
dep is in is in meltdown
and we constantly keep a close eye on
what's happening in scotland because i
mean the general feeling
is if one part of the union goes the
rest will unravel eventually
and there is a growing push to have a
border pole in northern ireland as well
and that will be strengthened if
an indie referendum was granted again
you'll find an increase in
the calls for a border pole in northern
ireland